Joshua is in Arizona hey Joshua how are
you hi I'm good can you hear me
barely how can we help ya so I have a
question about career I went to a trade
school and they had promised me a job
afterwards which I did accept but I got
let go from the job and I feel cheated
from the school because they didn't I
felt like they didn't train me correctly
how were you why would you let go they
said I couldn't perform the job properly
and do you agree with them or disagree I
disagree because I got with a different
company and they trained me correctly
and even my trainer I'm a truck driver
and even my trainer said that I should
somehow like fight the school or maybe
talk to Congress No
so you're successfully employed now
doing the thing that you went to school
to get trained to do driving a truck
correct yeah so you called us why
because I wanted to know like if I had
because I felt like I got cheated from
the school if that makes sense because
be specific I met you you didn't learn
to drive a truck there uh no they just
teach you how to pass the test to get
your license
they don't teach you like on the road
stuff right and things like that yeah
their promise their promise was to help
you pass the test or their promise was
to teach you on the road stuff to teach
me on the road stuff as well as passed
the test were you ever on the road with
the company no no not with them
with the school not with the school
while you were training you never drove
a truck in the yard but not like on the
road they have a little yacht where they
train people I say ok alright well I I
think you need to get real specific
about what you were promised I doubt
you're going to win this but if you
wanted to see an attorney is what you
would do
Congress can't help you better you could
talk to an attorney and ask them if you
have been mislead you obviously feel
misled but I I think if I never drove a
truck outside of a parking lot where I
practiced I don't think I would consider
myself a professional truck driver I
would consider myself a guy who had
driven a truck in a parking lot and had
passed the test so I don't I mean even
if they promised you that at the time
but you left the school you knew you
didn't know how to drive a truck over
the road right and that's and that's
where I feel sort of cheated by them
well you said you lost your job with the
company they placed you at correct yes
and that company owned the school okay
but you were you were let go because you
knew it they owned the school right and
they hard your truck after they knew
they didn't train you to drive a truck
um yes because the company has a
separate training program that you go
through but my trainers like slept in
the back the whole time while I was
driving and I tried to explain that to
them but they didn't care and I don't
know and let me tell you you can do what
you want to do how old are you I'm 24
okay I'll tell you what I would tell you
to do you can do what you want to
there's two options one is you can talk
to an attorney or two is there's a part
of this you need to own you didn't drive
a truck on the road and you knew that
you were driving with instructors who
were sleeping in the back and you knew
that so you knew that you didn't know
how to drive a truck and yet you went in
and took a job with that knowledge and
so this is partly on you if you go to
get training in they're not training you
you're supposed to stop and go hello I'm
supposed to be getting trained not wait
until afterwards when bad stuff happens
and blame it on them now granted it
sounds like they're a bunch of screw-ups
but you walked right through screw-up
land and never said a word dude and so
you need to own some of this if I were
you I would own my part of it and go
they're a bunch of screw-ups and I'll
do it and now I know how to drive a
truck and I got a job to heck with it
I'm going on my life I think you're
about to waste a whole bunch of your
emotions and your energy and I think
this is a life lesson it's not a legal
problem but you do what you want to do
your other option is to contact an
attorney
I don't know can three words let it go
yeah move on